[Music]
this is lecture 2 so we will continue
with geometry of high dimensions that's
what we are going to do for the first
two weeks I'm going to recap in one
slide before I start right this is what
we did already last time if you have
questions on this you can ask me
otherwise they will start doing new
stuff after this flight so we just I
didn't give you many examples but I just
told you that in a lot of situations
data points or J's vectors and RB real
space B dimensional real space right
each component is a real number positive
or negative and viewing them as vectors
is useful it's not just a bookkeeping
device to keep a list of things right
list of components again that's not
something that we will dwell into in
examples but that's something I told you
last time for what our main focus is to
see that for large number of dimensions
which is the case for a lot of
applications data is you know if you had
documents we saw the example of
documents being put down as vectors
there are as many components as there
are words in the language and also
webpages right the web being described
as a matrix and then there are as many
components as there are web pages and
the billion so these very large things
behave differently there is a starting
point and we wanted to see some
important differences so one of them was
that I told you and will prove that
today that the volume of this hyper
sphere I keep in exchanging these two
terms but they mean the same thing the
unit ball hyper sphere all means the
same thing is the set of X in R d such
that the length of X is less than or
equal to 1 and in the slides' vectors
will be both faced right here I can't do
that but
and I'll try to do that keep the
convention there vectors of bold-faced
and scalars or not both days right I
mean but not not on the board on the
board okay we'll see that will also this
other fact we saw this already so since
the recapping is mentioning it most of
the volume of any d dimensional object
is near the surface not just for first
years but for everything we've proved
already and there was no big deal in in
the proof except just a sort of calculus
thing that you divided the object into
tiny infinitesimal cubes and integrated
right and if you scale a cube down by 1
minus epsilon factor then you scale the
side down by the factor it's still a
cube that's worth checking and
furthermore the volume because there's D
dimensional jaskate scaled by this so
that's a that's a lot of serious scaling
in some sense because D is large this is
the D power right so if you go to 0.9
epsilon is 0.1 this is 0.9 you get 0.9
to the D which is very small
exponentially okay that's why the volume
is almost any other surface so we saw
these two things now I'm going to start
proving some of the other statements
that we didn't prove so I'll prove today
first we'll pour a bunch of things that
the volume of the D dimensional unit
ball will find it will actually more
than prove that it goes to zero will
actually find it so it is this integral
right I mean it's I'm writing down the
integral so that's a little bit of an
odd notation because it's D well D of X
1 X 2 and so on because the ad
dimensions D of X P bear with that so of
course X 1 goes from minus 1 to plus 1
and X 2 goes once I fix X 1 and X 2
squid can be at most 1 minus X 1 squared
because we are inside the unit sphere so
these are the limits this is the
integral and yesterday I said try
integrating it and I hope you did right
I mean I don't know how many of you did
but I you know
you get signed to various powers right
sine and cosine 2d powers or more if you
did it but if you did it you spend that
sort of in vain because they are going
to do something better just just to sort
of give you a feel for why it was you
know it's a multi-dimensional integral
is a bit of a hassle right so instead
we'll go to polar coordinates standard
thing that we do in three dimensions and
I'm going to draw a little picture on
the board now in polar coordinates I'm
going to write this down it seems
completely obvious except I'm going to
I'm going to try to impress upon you
that this is not completely automatic in
all cases save to a little more careful
but let's draw that picture right in two
dimensions or three dimensions two DS or
we can draw the picture is this right so
I guess I said what is D Omega D Omega
is infinitesimal surface element and R
is the radius polar coordinates right so
R is a radius so I'm integrating from R
equals 0 to 1 because the the whole ball
of radius 1 so at the particular R and
this is dr
okay so we want to take this
infinitesimal area surface area let me
say it really is a D - one dimensional
volume right if this was a - D you're
really doing an annuity it's a length of
the curve we're doing it in 3d it's the
area of the surface if you're doing it
in 4d is the three-dimensional volume of
this and so on so if you're doing it in
fourth you know candy this is a nine
dimensional object right so this is that
scaled by r right just killed by our R
is less than 1 in this case therefore
scaling by our a D minus 1 dimensional
object scales volume by this much right
so that's the world that's the area of
that okay and I'm multiplying by dr to
get this infinitesimal volume so this is
say anything i have to be a little
careful about in doing that or is that
completely automatic is it all is sort
of true that i mean it's true but okay
so let me ask you this question
instead suppose i had a square in two
dimensions and they did the same thing
right
this this is the cube this is r equals 1
and this is radial so here is another
this is our this is our equals 1 this is
T Omega again and this is is it still D
Omega times R to the D minus 1 I'm
sitting in D space so first question is
that is the infinite earth element all
to the D minus 1 times D Omega it is
actually that's not a problem
is it true that think about this is it
true that this is equal to R to the D
minus 1 D Omega D are
okay I won't give you the answer but
assume that that is true do an integral
you get the wrong area for the square
even in 2d so you know what's wrong yeah
these are the same picture more or less
that is wrong and this is correct
why is that right but no it's okay yeah
so the the D are okay so yeah what's the
what's the reason this is true the D are
here is orthogonal to the surface not so
there right so the two and three
dimensions mean we are familiar with
this but in D dimensions if the volume
of this would be equal to this times
that provided they're orthogonal
you must take only the height right you
must take the height just as you do in
two to three dimensions so D dimensional
volume of an infinitesimal volume is
infinitesimal surface area correct times
height but a perpendicular it cannot be
an angular height so as I said you get
the wrong answer if you do this and
integrate even into D you won't get the
right answer so I'll come back to this
point once more because in two and three
D we are familiar with this right but in
higher dimensions it may look alright
but it's not all right here they are
perpendicular the radial Direction is in
fact orthogonal to the tangential
Direction right so even even though so
this is a D minus one dimension okay
maybe in 3d this is a two-dimensional
surface right there's only one normal
one-dimensional normal work to space
right and that's just all that so that's
why that's correct for the sphere but
not necessarily always okay good
so so far for the ball it's true these
don't interact so I can move the
intervals around so I get R to the D
minus one D are D Omega comes out this
integrates to 1 over D of course and D
Omega integrates to
a of D where a of D is a surface area of
the D minus 1 dimensional unit ball so
it's a D might excuse me
so D dimensional unit ball the surface
is d minus 1 dimensional so all we have
done is related volume to surface area
so what we have done maybe it's worth
writing on the board is that the volume
equals D 1 over D 1 over D times surface
area and for the cube that's not true so
this argument fails that's not true but
it's what thinking about one thing this
argument does give something some
relationship between these two now what
does it give so does it give you
anything about volume and surface area
sorry lesson correct yeah it does tell
you that volume is at most surface area
divided by D and that's true for the
cube so I mean so you know that for the
square right if the site is to the
perimeter is 8 the area is 2 squared is
4 dimension is 2 they're equal but if
you go to three dimensions that's not
true so you see that it's less sorry but
it's always less than or equal to Y is
that that well less than or equal this
correct but why is that true sorry the
height cannot be more than the actual dr
right
dr is the high pot the height is a
projection of that so this is VR and
then the height is that it's dr is the
hypotenuse of the triangle so the height
is not at most like so it's true that
volume is at most one over T times
surface area for the sphere is exactly
equal but I'm now still left with a
problem of computing the surface area
and that's what I'm going to do okay
again if you did this multiple
integration you see that that's much
more complicated we'll do it with a very
nice trick and this trick okay so this
is a relation between the sphere and
gaussians and there are lots of
relationships we are going to see once
more the gaussian comes in very
naturally so y'all I presume you all
know what the Gaussian density is right
in 1d it's just e to the minus x squared
over two if its standard deviation is
one I've forgotten the two here because
I don't care about the standard
deviation and I've forgotten that I've
made it a normalizing constant so I'm
just going to consider this integral
where the limits are plus to minus
infinity minus infinity so the limits
are simple so the integrand can be
factored so you get this and this is
root pi so if you down
the book there's a proof that this
integral is ruled by I guess I won't do
that just a definite interval you know
for instance if you want to compute the
normalizing constant for the Gaussian
that's the interval you want right so
you get that I of T is this so in the
appendix of our book we we have a proof
of that standard thing I said do on the
board but maybe not now I'm going to
write this I of G now polar coordinates
okay and it's it's okay so again it's
worth going to that picture so now
instead of I'm trying to integrate e to
the minus length of x squared so that
quantity here is e to the minus R
squared and you still have R to the D
minus 1 the value of the function is
either miles R squared the area is or to
the D minus 1 D Omega D are again we've
removed the D Omega and then I have to
do this integral this is a moment of
this integral you need to do if you want
to compute the D minus 1 moment of the
Gaussian right so that's what that's
what that is doing and you do that so
I'm gonna go over not all the details
but I'll tell you some of the
substitutions just to get this right so
we put it's a gamma function basically
so you put R squared equals V do you
substitute R squared equals T and you'll
get that
provided I didn't make a mistake so you
get this integral this is again what's
called the gamma function its gamma of D
over 2 I guess I did not say that here
gamma is related as you know to the
factorial function right gamma of n plus
1 is n factorial
but gamma is defined or any real value
so it's defined whether or not you're
integers for integers it's a factorial
but it's defined always by that by that
mechanism right so gamma of something
here B over two is e to the minus T that
thing minus one it's a moment of the
exponential probability density right e
to the minus T is an exponential
probability density it's a moment of
that so that so that's a way to compute
I of D but we know that I of T is that
from the previous slide so we equate
these two that gives me a of D and this
gives me D of D okay so that's the
volume ins of this area of the sphere so
as you see this is much simpler to do
once you connect with a Gaussian then
perhaps we did by just multiple
integration now the thing to observe
from this is gamma of T I didn't say
that on the slide but gamma of D come up
D over 2 is less than or equal to C to
the D D to the D over 2 it's like the
factorial function it's like the
factorial function so in factorial you
know is the N to the N over either then
approximately it was a root n but I
think Hooten is upstairs
this is Sterling's approximation so so
that is going to lead us okay before I
go on I did draw that picture here
that's just the same picture as that and
written but I stressed the point that
the 90-degree is important so the angle
the DR and surface a is perpendicular
I've already said that but we want to be
careful that that's true before we claim
that that is the volume okay now so that
proof is finished and I'm going to have
four or five observations about the
proof before
I go on to the next theorem the first
worry or question is the following d
dimensional units fear is just if I take
a d-plus one dimensional sphere cut it
in the middle I get a D dimensional
sphere so d dimensional sphere is a
subset of the D minus 1 dimensional
sphere it's just a equatorial plane if
you want right so that would seem to say
that the volume should be in that order
right we know that's not true
even in three dimensions in three
dimensions unit ball has volume 4/3
right foot maybe it's true in three
dimension well I may be wrong 4/3 PI R 4
3 PI R cube 4/3 pi I write for the
volume and the area of a circle of
radius 1 is PI R squared so the volume
is in fact greater than so okay I was
wrong there so I think you have to go to
6 dimensions so V of 6 is not greater
than or equal to V of 5 but 2 and 3 it's
true so is that ok so we know that it's
not true ultimately because as I said
the lemma implies asymptotically V of T
you see the D divided by D to the D over
2 this is a gamma function there was
then the last slide so this obviously
goes to 0 not only that if I take V of G
over V of D plus 1 pretend I mean if
they are okay there is you have to be a
little more careful because it's not a
very nice function that the limit exists
so simply but pretend the limit exists
this limit is what from that formula
here suppose you believe that then
what's the limit as B goes to infinity
of BFD over V of T plus 1 just C over
root D roughly but it goes to 0 right
just goes to 0 so obviously it's false
a emphatically we have D plus one is
less than we have D even though in two
and three dimensions is not the case
okay so why are these two not
contradictory statements so that's what
thinking about for a minute right
so again the D dimensional sphere is a
subset of the D plus 1 dimensional yet
it's volume seems to be more
asymptotically when D is large enough
so is that is that contradictory or not
it's not contradictory because it's true
anybody wants to think of a way a reason
that it's not contradictory yeah so
because there it's comparing apples and
oranges exactly right so comparing these
two is comparing apples and oranges
because you just I mean in two and three
dimensions this is square feet this is
cubic feet so you don't say that five
square feet is less than or equal to six
cubic feet right just a sanity check now
a little more a little harder question
so in this integration I use the
Gaussian I pulled it out of the Hat
right so going back to slides I just
pulled this eye of tea out of the Hat
right and then related it so what i did
was i computed i of t two ways one way
led led me to a formula involving the
surface area another way led me to a
closed form polar polar coordinates but
closed form formula and I related the
two to get the surface area so I pulled
it out of the Hat now is there something
else you can do besides Gaussian so
Gaussian is e to the minus x squared
length of x squared this is Euclidean
length so if you will the two norm right
so could I have used the one norm
instead so I could I could try to do the
integral I could try to do I prime D is
equal to the integral of e to the minus
one norm of X DX and try to relate that
to the surface area can I do that what
might go wrong if you try to do that the
continuity yeah it's okay it's not
continuous but we're integrating not
differentiating so that may not be a
problem so two things happen which are
nice for us when we use Gaussian it's
probably worth noting these properties
of the Gaussian maybe I should have said
that so here's one thing that happened
right we were able to split it up into
just a product
of one dimension integrals which we know
how to do there's that's fact number one
what's the other nice thing that
happened hmm
constant radially symmetric so we got
this so we also got this where it's a
function of just R that means it's
radially symmetric right at the same R
this function is that function is the
same value so the Gaussian is the only
thing that has both these properties
where it's separable you can split it up
and it's radially symmetric right so I
cannot use that I cannot use I cannot
use even e to the minus length of X even
the clearing length of X that doesn't
split right it's not the product of one
dimensional integrals so I needed both
symmetry that is that only dependent on
R plus the splitting so Italian is used
in many contexts because of these
properties right it's the only thing
that has all these properties
oh I forgot yeah I was reminded that I
should repeat the questions from the
audience because they can't record it so
I have to repeat them next time we saw
that radial symmetry is crucial as well
as the splitting which I didn't write
down I should do that and then this is a
question I already went through it's a
survey they have any D dimensional
object D times its volume picture proof
of the same argument that is a picture
proof as four spheres works for anything
so the picture proof seems to work is
this picture correct right we went
through that already and we did get
though this quantity that's nice to know
this is true you can you should check
all these things for small dimensional
spheres and so on
just as a sanity check so now we will
prove that the volume is near the
equator so we're going to prove several
of these things so this will be by
integration there's no gaussian trick
here but it'll be by integration we will
come back to using gaussians for more
things little later so we want to prove
that most of the volume say 99% of the
volume of the DC air is in the
equatorial region and the equatorial
region is the absolute value of x1 so
above and below the equator equatorial
plane right is less than or equal to
Delta so first intuition intuitive
question I'm going to ask is what Delta
should be and then we'll try to prove it
right so here is that a nice thing to
just there's something that you all know
but this is very central to this course
so I want to remark on this right that
first question is the same as a question
that I can rephrase in terms of
probabilities right I want to know the
98th in the 99th percentile of the
absolute value of x 1 when x is picked
uniformly at random
we'll use this phrase a lot so I'm going
to abbreviate it you a are uniformly at
random from the hyper sphere so again
this is extremely intuitively simple
right that
just think of that so volumes and
volumes and probabilities are related
after all probability is just an
integral of probability density and
volume is also an integral so you expect
the relation but this is what we're
asking
so more intuition of what Delta should
be so here's more intuition right so the
length of x squared is just photograph's
right some of the coordinates squared we
know that the expected value of the
length of experience of most one in fact
a length of X is at most one in the
sphere not least at most one we actually
know that it's approximately one right
so how close is it to one do you know
the answer what's the expected value of
x squared from what we already seen what
is it what can you put here that's true
one minus one over T right because we
saw that most of the volume I mean it's
not completely a proof you have to sit
and work it out
but that probability was falling
exponentially so you should be able to
integrate to get one minus one over D so
in fact expect early of x squared is 1
minus C over D for a particular constant
C you can work that out by symmetry they
all the expected value of x1 squared X
must all be equal so each of them is 1
over D so that suggests that Delta which
is absolute value of x1 without the
square could be order 1 over root D but
we want that to hold with high
probability
that's only expectation right so these
are expectations it doesn't imply high
probability automatically that tells you
an intuition by the way even though for
okay so sorry let's go through this for
a general random variable let's consider
x1 absolute value to be a general random
variable in a second moment at most 1
over D we saw that that's this stuff
okay does that automatically imply that
with high probability high probability
means exponentially small failure
probability it's 1 over root D or the 1
over root D that's not true
general random variables can have
terrible tails
so if you had a polynomial density the
tail is so long that this won't be true
what for all the geometric quantities we
are going to see the tail will not be
bad it'll be exponential so we already
saw two exponential bounds one is for
the volume near near the surface
sorry volume of is in the surface where
exponentially small another one was the
equator so things work with very high
probability so in fact even though this
is not rigorously correct it'll be true
by the way
one quick aside as a recap I would like
to prove and will prove this with high
probability x1 is 1 over root II we do
know the expected value of x1 squared is
at most 1 over D can you at least say
this the expected value of the absolute
values at most one over root D do we
know this to be implied from what we
know already
anybody remember an inequality that
might give you this
cauchy-schwarz yo Jensen's inequality is
called but proved by cauchy-schwarz so
for any random variable X the expected
value of the absolute value of x is less
than or equal to the expected value of x
square root and you prove it
this is Jensen's inequality right you
prove it by taking square roots
what is the convexity of the square
function any number of ways but that's
true so we do know that but I want to
tell you that in fact even though it's a
fallacious argument to say expectation
implies that high probability it's order
that it's true for geometric quantities
right so they are fairly concentrated so
we'll do bi will do a proper proof by
integration so I should draw a picture
on the board so I'll erase this
well I'm going to find the volume of the
following set what is this thing a set
of Y so that x1 is greater than or equal
to both top and bottom that case I made
a mistake there's a factor of two
missing sorry so what I have what I have
here is only that top part and it should
be t minus 1 there excuse me
so should be C over D minus 1 so in the
picture I will indicate all this so this
is C over root t minus 1 minus C over
root 3 minus 1 I'm integrating this I'm
taking slabs and integrating so this is
a slab and this is X 1 this is DX 1 the
volume of this slab what is it so it's
this is radius 1 so little geometry here
this is radius 1 this is just basically
planar because all dimensions are
symmetric and this is X 1
now the I'm going to take the D minus 1
dimensional volume of this okay this is
a sphere of radius so this flat thing I
guess I should have drawn this big case
of sphere in D minus 1 dimensions or
gradient right and therefore it's volume
is so I'm sorry therefore that so volume
right so yeah the question is whether it
shouldn't be multiplied by 2 the answer
is yes I made a mistake and then put the
2 there because I need the this is only
computing the top right so yeah I will
correct this right yeah you have to have
a true that good so I get it it's d
minus 1 dimensional sphere of radius 1
has this volume we have D minus 1 but
now it has radius square root of 1 minus
X 1 square so again you get that extra
factor and times V X 1
ok so is this correct am I being careful
about the point I made right yes DX 1 is
perpendicular to that to this sure
that's fine ok so here's a nice standard
trick I mean I'm going to tell you some
of these tricks
they're just integration tricks but then
we use them quite often so for the
Gaussian integrals these are tails so
when you want to compute the tail
probability of a Gaussian right the
probability that X is very many standard
deviations away this is what you have to
do this is the integral so you get X
minus of x over X is greater than alpha
and this is alpha by the way X is
greater than office I can throw that and
this is nice because this is integrable
right either minus x squared the
derivative has an X in it so you can
integrate that
so that's how you often compute the tail
probability of the Gaussian so that's a
very good estimate if you go more than a
few standard deviations away okay so I
have to integrate that sorry I have to
integrate that and I throw in this extra
factor this x over alpha factor here
right and I want to claim that is that
it needs only to be checked but
basically we D minus 1 comes out that's
that see you know you can check that you
can check that there's no mistake that
yeah
was that a question I think I've made no
mistakes but it's worth checking to make
sure in the book these are written down
more steps are written down so that you
can check ok and now I want to I want a
denominator so so I wanted the ratio of
the volume of a to BFD now we've got
volume of a in terms of V of D minus 1
and my object now is to get V of T in
terms of VF d minus 1
roughly
we FG is V of G minus one over square
root of D because we lose as quite it's
the volume is D to the D over two in the
denominator so you lose the square root
of D each time so that's what roughly is
true but we will prove that so I'm sorry
so here's a proof volume of the hyper
sphere that's V of G's at least the
volume of the cylinder of this height
contained in there so it's the volume of
this kind of cylinder so I'm going to
take that volume as a lower bound on the
volume of the whole thing again there
are a few more steps in the notes if you
don't agree with something you can ask
me so which is now why is that okay
let's see if that if you agree with that
so this is supposed to be the volume of
the cylinder whose height is 2 divided
by root D minus 1 so it's 1 divided by
root D minus 1 away from the equatorial
plane so why do you get this factor why
do you get that
roughly what is this what is this factor
coming from from from the fact that this
thing has radius 1 minus x squared
square root and then this height is this
2 over root P minus 1 so I think that's
also done correctly worth checking but
so at the end of it you get a theorem
which says that for any constant C
greater than 1 C is anything greater
than 1 more than D dimensions more than
three dimensions you have the at most
this fraction of the volume of the
sphere has X 1 greater than this amount
so again I expect the absolute value x1
to be lovely 1 over D 1 over root D
sorry I put down 1 over root B minus 1
here which is about the same these large
so the probability that is greater than
that falls off exponentially with see
all of these things will be exponential
false tales would be very tails very
very well behaved ok again please do
check all the details
so I guess the question is why did we
recompute V of T in step 6
that's because I wanted the denominator
and the numerator to be in terms of V of
D minus 1 so that's not a very
interesting question now this result
implies a bunch of things it's another
way to prove it's another way to prove
so the equator being heavy there's
another way to prove that the volume of
the whole sphere goes to zero and that
requires another picture so I'll draw
fresh so we prove that if I put here C
times root log D in the last slide I had
only a scene now I'm putting a C times
root log B hey Rudy minus 1 but almost
the same as root D then the volume was e
to the minus the squid so I put the root
log B so that I get e to the minus this
volume I will get e to the minus C log D
because I squared it times the volume of
the sphere which with large enough C is
less than 1 over d squared at least 2
let's say it's a at least 1 over d
squared that's for the X 1 axis and I
could do the same thing for the X 2 axis
this is X 2 and I know okay so let me
this shaded region is small but from the
X 2 picture I also know that this shaded
region is
now if I take out those two shaded
regions in two dimensions in D
dimensions I have to take out D of them
what's left is a cube you have to
convince yourself but what is left is a
cube right I mean so let's I think it's
the next statement okay it doesn't say
precisely but so yeah so it does say
here so it's 1 over d squared each of
those things I take out and I have to
take out D of them one for each axis so
once I take them all out I've still only
taken out one over D of the volume so
for example half the volume is still
left but that's all inside the cube now
the cube has a much smaller side than
the radius of the sphere because the
cube has only side about root log B over
D again D is going to infinity so this
is going to zero so it's a tiny cube
right so what this is saying is that a
tiny cube in the center of the sphere
contains half the volume or again
another not a surprise anymore because
we've seen many of these things and the
cubes volume is the side raised to the
power D so now the volume of the sphere
we saw more exactly did not have this
log factor right it still had this
factor that is correct
that's a higher order term that's
correct but it didn't have the log
factor this is a crude argument which
leaves the log factor in
but that's still going to zero because
log D is much smaller than D so that's
another another proof I mean you can
give multiple proofs that this goes to
zero okay so I yeah you mean I mean that
this you mean this thing the D minus 1
dimensional volume is near the D minus 1
dimensional surface which is the
equatorial plane that right answer so
maybe we should revisit that symmetry
question which which I meant to which is
remember we had this puzzle
last time from Maisie maybe you asked
the question to write that every so
anything can be any anything can be the
North Pole you know I don't care it's
not fixed so for every not pole so you
see this region has 99% of the volume so
does this region right and so on so how
do we reconcile that ok that may be
there even we didn't quite answer that
question that's what revisiting so why
is that not contradictory right so if
you intersect so if it's 99 percent if
you intersect ten of them you the
intersection will have only ten 90
percent perhaps right so they intersect
huge the number of them the intersection
could be very small so will contain the
origin but it will be very small so it's
it's not a contradiction the other
little thing was the equator and and the
surface so everything was near the
surface everything was near the equator
so these things are very heavy these
things together contain 99 percent 98
percent of the volume of the sphere it
doesn't look at all possible in 3d or 2d
but it's true because we could have we
did say it's it's all near the surface
and it's all in equatorial plane so
that's okay so another consequence of
the equator thing is that is a general
principle in some sense if I pick two
independent random vectors UV and so I'm
writing here the expectation of a vector
what I mean is component wise who take
expectations right usually you take
expectations of real value random
variables so each component you take the
expectation and there's zero vectors so
all each component of U and V have
expectation zero and they are
independent then with high probability
it's another face we'll use a lot so
I'll use W HP for high probably with
high probability usually it means
exponentially small probability of
failure right these vectors U and V will
be nearly orthogonal you will not have a
we will not have a component very much
of a component along you will make it
point to will quantify that so
intuitively this is clear but dot
products measure correlation and this
says that independent vectors will not
be correlated right so intuitively that
should be the case and in fact it is the
case right so we'll prove that using the
equator thing let's prove something
stronger so the the way to see that for
two vectors and I'm going to do it for
multiple vectors in a minute for two
vectors if u and V are independent
uniform at random from the unit sphere
will see that the dot product is very
small compared to the lines first the
length is big right
the with high probability the length of
X length of U is this big so that's
clear right why is that what result
implies that just a sanity check volume
near the surface implies that so yeah so
that that implies that so first we pick
u and then I'm going to rotate the
coordinate system so that use a North
Pole
I'm allowed to do that I can choose any
North Pole so then u becomes this vector
with only the first component zeros near
the components now I pick V now V is
independent of U so the rotation does
not affect how we looks right the change
of coordinate system it doesn't affect
what are we looks like and we saw from
the
create a result that with high
probability the absolute value of v1 is
order 1 over root D and now I take the
dot product I only have to worry about
v1 and it so the cosine theta which is
the dot product divided by the length is
something like this 1 over root T times
the length of U is that that's roughly
the higher order terms but it's roughly
1 of a routine and that implies theta is
almost 90 degrees cosine inverse is that
okay that's what two vectors what
happens if I pick n vectors if I pick n
vectors iid in d dimensional space I can
one can prove first all of them near the
line near the surface
if log in is much smaller than D and
secondly all the dot products are small
again log this is a log if log in is not
very big compared to D that's n is
smaller than 2 to the D then the dot
products also go to 0 so let me not
actually prove this guess I don't know
maybe I'll ask questions about so how do
we do the first one I want to say that
with high probability all the X I or big
and I want to get the log factor first
where would I get that the first one x1
is big in length let me solve that's
from the volume near the surface how
would I get that all of them are near
the surface union-bound right so because
the probability that one of them sorry
the answer was Union so the probability
that one of them is not near the surface
whatever it is and then you have to
multiply it by n but the failure
probability is exponential so you get a
log this is a calculation that you can
do at home how about this xixj so we
prove for one pair UV we get u dot be
small I mean we did some rotate
coordinates and so on but those ought to
be ignored the it's all independent of
the coordinate system so how do we get
this same Union bound right because
there are N squared of them now maybe I
should do that but there are N squared
of them so if P is the probability of
failure of one of them probability that
X 1 dot X 2 is greater than or equal to
that quantity 6 root log n over root t
minus 1 then I want n squared times P
now this probability I know is less than
or equal to e to the minus before we let
C squared or see that's the equator
thing is C squared right so yeah so it's
it's a square of this basically it's log
in times some constant
I think 1006 squared divided by 2 I mean
you have to go back to that actual so
this is less than or equal to 1 over N
to the N now the N squared we have to
Union n squared events not any events
but the N squared only costs you a
factor of 2 more because they're taking
logs that's the point again please
worked it out that's just a union bound
that gets you that so even if I pick a
lot of vectors they're all fairly
mutually orthogonal so I want to do one
more thing and then how do you pick
uniform random points actual algorithmic
ly how do you sample points when a unit
ball so in two and three D the algorithm
the simplest algorithm to do that is the
following so I want to pick a uniform
random point from this circle that's a
bit difficult because the coordinates
are dependent right because we have this
constraint X 1 square plus X 2 square
less than or equal to 1 so the
coordinates are not independent so you
put it in a box of sight 2
and I pick random points from the box
now I can do that because X 1 and X 2
are independent and I accept the point
only if it's inside the sphere this is
called a rejection sampling right in
statistics that I mean the detection
something is just saying the following
I want a sample from the distribution
which is somewhat hard which is uniform
distribution on the sphere P of X in
this case I instead draw a sample for an
easier distribution Q of X which is
uniform in the cube because they're
independent and then except with this
probability it's easy to check that the
samples I get or correct iid samples the
distribution P of X there's a profound
question would you do the same procedure
if I've told you to pick from a thousand
dimensional sphere a uniform random
point would you do the same procedure in
a thousand dimensional sphere no the
answer is he's shaking his head but you
know that's why wouldn't you do it yes
so the answer is yes the volume of the
sphere is exponentially smaller so you
reject most of the time so the cube is
so much bigger than than the sphere that
this would make rejection very likely so
in fact this is a general phenomenon
which we won't do in this course but if
you see one of the later chapters of our
book on Markov chains it turns out to be
interesting to pick random uniform
points from general sets let's say
convex sets simplices cubes spheres
polytopes in very high dimensions and
rejection something does not work for
this very reason because the enclosing
object is always much bigger so what do
you do if it doesn't work you can look
up that chapter or I could give you a
little we won't actually do that in this
course you employ a Markov chain Monte
Carlo method but so so you wouldn't do
this in
thousand dimensions here's a procedure
that does work for Sears it doesn't work
for general objects and that's much more
complicated for spheres the correct
procedure is we pick X 1 3 X 3
independent from standard Gaussian this
is mean 0 variance 1 normal density
now you take you normalize the links to
1 that's a uniform random point of
length 1 from the surface of the sphere
but if we want to pick from inside so
I'm going to scale it by a factor row
and take that as my sample so again I
have a sphere I picked a Gaussian point
X with Gaussian density over all of
space and then I scaled it down to x
over length of X then I'm going to scale
it down to one of these points this is
Rho times that but I have to pick row
with the correct density those are real
random variable I have to pick it with
the correct density right what is the
density of Rho uniform is not right
right
it's not uniform over 0 1 yeah so which
is it's running from but yeah it's got
to be the area but what might it be so
you have to look again at the
differential element right so I want
that volume and that volume should be a
function of Rho to the D minus 1 so Rho
probability that Rho is equal to X is
proportional to X to the I mean divided
by R into R which is V but you have to
normalize it but so you have to pick a
row with the correct density and then
you get a point
uniformly at random from this
ah big question or such a bit so I think
yes the question is in speaking
according to the normal what if I pick X
1 to X 3 independent minus R to plus R
uniform right so what is wrong that
doesn't work why not
okay so we should draw a picture I think
that's one of the homework problem so
anyway what the suggestion was this
right so here I pick a point uniformly
at random from the cube and then scale
it down to length 1 so I pick it
somewhere here let's say and then scale
it down to this so will that be correct
No so yes the answer is no but why won't
it be correct some directions are more
points which direction has more points
the corner right here because yeah the
cone here is very very long so this
volume is much bigger than this right so
so you need a radius radially symmetric
density in any case but any radially
symmetric density will do so if I pick
points with probability you to the - so
Gaussian is e to the minus R squared I
could instead do e to the minus R that's
fine but it has to be radially symmetric
okay so we'll go today the next time I'm
going to do the following we are going
to prove an annulus theorem for the
Gauss for gaussians that if I pick a
Gaussian it's also true that there's a
small annulus their points lie and to do
that we'll need a concentration result
which is actually quite general so it's
saying that sums of independent random
variables are concentrated which will
prove and that will imply Chernov and
all kinds of